i'm going to advocate
for getting involved in these bad boys
here
this is a trail camera and trail cameras
exist
primarily i think for hunters hunters
put these
up in places in order to figure out
where the game is and
when it's around and when it isn't
around but
they are also widely used now by
naturalists to figure out
what the behavior patterns of animals
are
and it's also tremendously fun just to
figure out
whether or not you're studying creatures
to figure out what's available so
i will yeah um at tippatini in the
ecuador and amazon where that picture
that you
showed of me in the angle boots was
taken
um there was a long time camera trap
study
uh with uh run by a man named diego
moscara who at that point was the field
manager for the station
and with the with the help of these
so-called camera traps these game
cameras
he found that there were um i think
there was
primatologists already knew that there
were 10 species of primates but it was
his camera trap work
um that revealed five different species
of cats of wild cats at tippettini and
so they're
super useful as a research tool as well
totally and yeah i must say it is
marvelously fun and addictive to deploy
these things hey you learn a lot you
deploy them somewhere you think is going
to be good and it isn't and you sort of
you learn a lot about the animals just
in figuring out where they're going to
be
things you couldn't possibly validate
without the camera because
the animals are really good at avoiding
you in many cases and so
anyway these come in different kinds um
they come
in a regular flash camera version that
takes night photos with the flash i'd
recommend against that
and then there are two versions that
don't spook the animals there's a low
glow
that has a light red glow animals do not
see red in general nocturnal animals
don't
and then there's a no glow pure infrared
one and anyway
they record a little sd card whatever
they see and then you come collect the
sd card there's some fancy ones now that
if you have cell service where you
deploy them they will
email you images of animals that happen
by
which can be kind of neat
i have i've deployed a couple cameras in
a local
wildlife area so the story is i was down
there on my bike
and actually somebody recognized me
and i was talking to them and as we were
talking looking out over the nature
reserve there was clearly
some sort of large-bodied mammal but we
didn't know what it was
and anyway i narrowed it down it had to
be one of a number of things it
had to be either otter or beaver or
could be link um well
i was already interested i knew there
were minks in this nature area and i was
interested to figure out where they were
do they swim much uh minx yeah minks are
always found
on the shore of water i don't know i
mean i'm sure they can swim but i don't
know that they do swim all that much but
they are
closely associated with water so otter
beaver or nutria where the three most
likely sort of the three
most likely suspects and that so i went
down there and started poking around a
little bit
uh that picture of the bald eagle in
flight that i showed last time was me
standing there trying to
get a bead on these mammals and the bald
eagle flew over
um and anyway i did see the animals a
second time but i couldn't figure out
what they were they were too far off
and so i set up two multiple two animals
yeah
large bodied dark low
so anyway i deployed a game camera and
uh zach do you want to show
what i came up with after about two
weeks of
why don't you show all of it
okay so here's the first thing that
is a beaver can you step through the
images
so that is a beaver emerging from the
water being
filmed with infrared there you can see
its eye shining back at the camera
here's the second beaver coming out of
the water it's going to go up slope here
[Music]
all right so beaver that's really
exciting beaver is a rodent
and it's one of my favorite rodents such
an interesting creature
they can be very shy here's the second
creature that the camera picked up now i
think this is a muskrat and not a nutria
it could be a nutrient though my my
sense of it's being something it's
squatter then
yeah it's a little smaller but nutria
and muskrat so watch this it's going to
take off into the water here
and once it's in the water it's almost
indistinguishable really yep yeah
all right nice um keep going zach
here's during the day oh look it's a
pair of river otters
so this is a nature area that is on a
tributary
of the willamette river which runs right
through portland
and so these are two river otters that
presumably enter the water here and then
swim right out into the willamette and
hunt fish and
maybe and shake their little otter fists
at the boaters
probably they do here you can see it's
raining as they're descending into the
water that's what i think we saw
looking out at the uh i'm pretty sure it
was going to be otters that were
glumping along
when i couldn't identify when you were
talking with the guy yeah for one thing
it was during the day
and the otters here it's not i mean and
the beavers here are
um at least partially nocturnal probably
entirely nocturnal
and now this last one is going to be a
little bit difficult to make out
but um it's on a crocodile isn't it no
for those of you who are photographers
rule of thirds
in the vertex of thirds in the lower
left-hand part of the
screen you've got a little four-legged
animal
uh with a long tail there that is a mink
so this one camera this is all from one
camera it was all from one camera over
the course of it looks like less than a
week yeah
in the days once in one go this camera
caught all of these things
and it's amazing i mean hey this is i
mean to be to be fair though
you know you've got decades training
honing a naturalist psi
not just as a field biologist but also
as a photographer and so
you put it in the right place right like
you could have put it somewhere where it
wouldn't have caught anything
i did and indeed i've got one uh
deployed right now that
caught absolutely nothing so that's a
thing that happens
and you know uh anyway it's a fun game
if you want a game that
you know is is very real figuring out
how to get the wildlife to show up on
your
game camera is um is a pretty good one
and so i guess uh yeah you want to show
the video this is from our backyard
this is a coyote they unfortunately in
portland
uh hunt house cats quite actively
and this is literally oh probably
40 feet from our back deck beautiful
animal
um so that's actually from last two
years ago yeah
that is from two years ago just a very
high quality video so it does prove that
you can get
really good quality uh video and
pictures off
out of these things if you place them
carefully and uh
um anyway yeah so that's uh cool stuff
so yeah you've been getting some
um we've got unfortunately three coyotes
right here
over the last several days uh oh yeah
pictures of we have been
yeah and i will show some pictures at
some point indeed actually last week
people remember i was looking at an
animal out the window that i said was
very dark
i now know from multiple kinds of
evidence that it had to be a coyote in
my sense that it was very dark
was off everything else adds up maddie
went to the spot
and immediately picked it out and
started looking around for something and
now i've camera trapped around the area
the coyotes
come right through there and so that's
what i saw out the window
and for those of you who might be
concerned are if you hear yelling
now it's because our cats are pissed
because they're not allowed outside
while there's this many coyotes right
here who are clearly waiting for them
yeah they're waiting for snacks um but
anyway
think about whether i mean you can get
these pretty cheap you know for
a hundred bucks you can you can get one
that does the basics and then you know
you can go up from there
um you got any in particular that you
recommend because you've now got a few
different
types yeah i would say i don't i
wouldn't worry too much about
no glow versus low glow i think low glow
is just fine doesn't spook the animals
at all um but don't go flash
yeah don't go with the visible flash um
i would say
i like the bushnell cameras
get one that has a screen so you can see
what the camera is going to shoot rather
than being surprised when you pick up
your sd card
yeah and it's also really useful if they
have
a a visible led and a setting to
test where the trigger zone is
so basically you can set it to test and
then you can walk out where you expect
an animal to be if you're on a deer
trail or something like that and you can
just make sure
that if you walk there you see the led
go off then you know it triggers
um but anyway yeah i like the bushnell
ones are pretty good
and i would say you can go to trail cam
pro the website and they have very good
reviews on things and you can see
you know they have all kinds of stuff
that you can bolt things to trees and
um they all come with a strap for a
reasonably small tree you can
just strap them onto the the tree it's
easier to aim them if you have something
with a little bit of a you know tripod
head
versatility like that but anyway it's a
fun game
and i'd be curious what you come up with
if you do manage to
to capture something beautiful